- Hello.
Welcome to Ed talks with Khan Academy.
I am excited today to
talk to Pedro De Bruyckeye
and my apologies in
advance for not having the
correct Belgian pronunciation of his name.
He is an author who has
authored a number of books.
We're gonna talk today about
urban myths about learning
and education.
And I'm excited to dive into
what we know from research
that may disprove or suggest we are wrong
about some of the things
that we hold to be true
about learning and education.
I will remind you that Khan
Academy is a non-profit
organization,
and we are able to do our work
through generous donations
from folks like yourself.
If you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you will be able to contribute
and help keep us moving
and working through
and doing all of the work that we do.
So thank you for your
consideration of that.
We also want to thank a
number of organizations
who've stepped up during COVID-19
to help support our work,
including Bank of America,
AT&T, Google.org, Novartis,
Fastly, and General Motors.
A reminder,
if you want to get an
audio version of this
or any other Ed talk or a homeroom,
and we have those available
in podcast version.
Homeroom with Sal: the podcast,
is available wherever
you get your podcasts.
So with that, we're going
to talk today as I said,
to the author of both of these books,
Urban Myths About Learning and Education
and More Urban Myths about
learning and education.
Pedro, thanks for joining us.
- Thank you for having me.
Good.
Hello.
- Hello!
So the first question I like to ask folks
is to tell me a little bit
about how you got here.
How did you end up writing
books about wording and
education?
- Well, it's, it's a funny story.
I remember one evening, eight
years ago, nine years ago,
and I was asked to be
the Statler and Waldorf
in a kind of education setting.
And my only job was to give funny remarks.
So I thought "Great."
And half way during the second
talk at a certain point,
one of the speakers was mentioning
that we have a creative brain
half and rational brain half,
and I forgot that my mic was on.
And I said, "Oh no, my bullshit
detector is now in the red."
And everybody was watching,
(Kristen laughs)
"What, what did you say?"
And every time I still,
when I'm meet that speaker,
I still apologize for that moment.
But he said to the audience,
I have to admit he's right.
He's correct.
(Pedro exhales)
But afterwards,
a lot of people came over
to me and started asking,
"but is this correct?
Or what about this?"
And I heard so many different myths
and said somebody should
do something about this.
And I was working my PhD,
but I had a writer's block, I
have to admit, at that time.
- And so,-
- Oh, been there, yes.
- Yeah, we all have been there, I guess.
And so I asked,
I asked my publisher,
can I write a little small
book about urban myths
in education?
And that was the starting point.
Now the book has been
translated in English, Chinese,
Turkish, Spanish, and it,
and it has traveled the whole world.
And I have traveled the whole
world talking about this.
- And you managed to finish your PhD.
That's really impressive.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know how I've done
that, but I've done it, yes.
- I understood.
So how did you gather all
of these different myths?
- Well,
the first book was pretty easy
because we could look at
research with common myths
and common misunderstandings.
And actually if we followed
the news just for one year,
we already had a lot of them.
And after the first book,
we thought, maybe a bit
naive, that we were done.
But when the first book was published,
we received so many questions.
"Yeah but what about this?
And what about that?
And could you check this too?"
And the second book is just
based on all questions received
for the years after the
publication of the first book.
- Wow!
Nice.
So that was that, yeah.
Just raised all of these
questions for people.
Just starting to hear about it,
made them question other things.
That seems like that's
a good outcome for the
first book to make people question more.
- [Pedro] Yep, correct.
- [Kristen] So let's dive
into a couple of them.
We talk a lot here about
Khan Academy, at Khan Academy
about the importance of knowledge,
but there's this myth out there
that if you can Google something,
do you really need to learn
the knowledge piece of it?
How about that one?
What's your, what's your take?
- Well, it sounds reasonable.
But the first question is how
can you come up with the right
words to Google if you
don't know the subject,
but the second element
and that's more painful,
is that the algorithms
of, for instance, Google,
they are not always
aiming at correct answers,
but more aiming on what do
they think you want to know.
And sometimes this can be incorrect.
That's one thing,
but also if you look at
information you are receiving
and I'm not talking only about fake news
and stuff like that,
but you have a lot of people
who have the same name.
And so we have had in the
past some very interesting
discussions about famous artists,
but then they were
discussing football player
instead of the artists.
(Kristen chuckles)
But there's an other very
important option, important reason
because most of the
time you have to come up
with an answer straight away.
You have to know things
to learn new things.
If there's no prior knowledge,
you have nothing to connect it to.
And so you don't have the building blocks
for the next learning step.
And it's,
it's a bit of a quote I once said,
but I think it's sums it,
it sums it up quite nicely,
"On the internet you don't find knowledge,
on the internet you find information,
but what you need is the
knowledge to fact check
and to understand that information."
- That all makes sense.
And I like that knowledge
versus information,
a distinction, that's really interesting.
And I know the other piece is
when you were solving
more complex problems,
sometimes you need that base
knowledge to solve them.
And if you have to stop
every time to go Google
for that base knowledge,
you're gonna forget what you were doing,
solving the complex problem
while you're trying to find
an answer for the base one,
is that right?
- It's late in the evening over here.
And one of my sons was just
passing through, going to bed.
And actually I remember a
very nice example of this.
A couple of years ago,
he had to learn his tables
of multiplication by heart
and he hated it!
And he asked me, "Why do I need this?"
And then I went to a
door and I asked my son,
can you open this door?
Which he did.
And I said "Now try to imagine,
you can't remember how to open the door.
So every time you are coming to the door,
you have to try to open
it, try to figure it out,
how you need to do this.
You bang on the door, you
use a head for a second.
Okay.
If it's opened,
you can only hope for one thing,
that there is no second door,
because otherwise you
will have to start over
and over and over again.
Now you have to learn the
tables of multiplication
by heart.
And it takes a lot of effort,
but pretty soon you'll
need much more complex,
you'll see much more complex mathematics.
And if you need to calculate
your multiplications
at that time,
you will lose so much time and energy,
so you won't be learning something new.
- That totally makes sense, yes.
So I think that that importance
of knowledge for all,
there's not just one reason.
There's multiple reasons that,
that you've laid out here
on why it's important.
Makes sense.
All right.
One of the most pervasive things,
you talked about your detector going red,
learning styles.
That to me, it's so
common and people just,
it seems so attractive for people
is something to believe
that there's visual learners
and auditory learners.
And I hear it all the time.
Tell me your thoughts on that one.
- Well,
it was one of the very first
myths that I encountered
that put me on the right track.
Actually, a couple of
weeks ago, months ago,
Dan Willingham was on the show-
- Ah, yes.
Yes.
- And it was one of his videos
that put me on track
of trying to figure out
what about those learning styles.
And what we've seen is a
lot of people recognize it.
And first of all, it's true.
A lot of people do have
learning preferences.
Maybe some people like to read,
or some people like to listen,
but there is no of,
no clear correlation
between your learning
preference and better learning,
but still that gut feeling,
"Oh, it's correct."
But I can flip that gut feeling.
Just a question you have to
ask yourself as a teacher,
are you in favor of
pigeonholing in education?
No, because we think all
our pupils are different.
All our students have different.
Yeah but if you are using learning styles,
you are pigeonholing your
students in three, four
the maximum amount with NBTI,
16 holes, 16 boxes
but our children are
much, much more complex.
- Yes, yes.
And it always is the,
when you look at the research,
there's just, no, it's,
this isn't a case where,
"Oh, the research hasn't been done."
There's been lots and lots of studies.
And they just,
across all of them,
don't find this effect.
And I wonder if there's still,
if there's something here about research
versus my personal experience
that is causing this to be persistent
and the idea of people
having a preference.
- Well, there is something
else also happening in science,
for instance, in a lot of
people write about education.
And for instance,
an area that there is a lot of research is
on computers and learning.
But those studies not often are
being done by psychologists.
So what we've seen is a lot of research
for the past 10, 20
years done on computers
in education,
but mentioning learning styles,
not checking if this theory
is correct or incorrect.
So you will find actually
a lot of research,
not really on learning styles,
but mentioning learning styles,
feeding all the people
who think they believe
"Yeah but I've read it in a study."
Yeah but that study was
not done by psychologists
knowing their stuff.
They were done by computer scientists.
They were done by
educationalists, perfect people,
but they didn't know that
they were using something,
they were using something incorrect.
- Right, right.
That makes sense.
They almost assume that learning
styles was a thing before,
as an assumption of the
work that they were,
that they were doing, yeah.
Yeah, that makes sense.
So in that world of
computers and technology,
also a space that I'm interested in,
- No, really?
- We hear a lot about dig-
we hear a lot about digital natives and,
but digital natives want
something really different
with their education and their system.
What is the research there on that?
- Well,
digital natives first was
coined by Marc Prensky
in 2001 already.
And it was just based on
a couple of observations.
It was not based on actual research.
And again, it sounds logical
because if you give a device to one of
your children or your pupils or students,
they are very handy with it.
But there has been a lot of research
and Paul Kirschner and myself,
we've done a review on all the research
since 2001.
And what we've discovered
is that it's not true.
It's not the case.
You have to make a distinction
between the content side
and the strategic side on one side.
And well, the bottom
knowledge and it's true.
Young people, young
students are much better
in figuring out how
some device is working.
But if we are talking about the content,
but also how to use it,
also to know if something
is correct or incorrect,
then we see that they
are not that good at all.
Actually, if we look
at 30 and 40 year old,
they are much closer to
what has been described
as digital natives,
than 10 year old, 20 year olds.
- Ah, interesting.
I hadn't known that, that
piece of the last part.
I remember looking, trying to
find in Marc Prensky's book,
the research to support it,
but he was basically coining a term,
but without having necessarily
the resources to support it
and it caught on, yeah.
- And there was a lot of research
and we've,
we are,
we keep checking all the research
because maybe now it will change,
but we didn't find any evidence yet.
And in different different
regions, for instance,
in, in China or Japan, we
can't find digital natives.
We can't find them in Europe.
We can't find them in the United States.
So, sorry.
Actually, it's a very important message
because it's very important
for us as educators,
as teachers,
we need to train our students
in how to handle these devices,
how to work on the internet,
how to handle the
information they are getting,
but also to know when they
can use their cell phone
and when it's better to put it away.
I think that the fact that
there are no digital natives
gives us an extra task in education.
- The idea of digital,
digital literacy and what that means.
it's so important,
but people have to be taught
it just like other skills.
Yeah.
- I guess so.
- Yeah.
We have a question from, from Facebook,
@malhafiz says "In today's
digital world we have knowledge,
but how can we solve problems
that many students,
you know, have degrees, but
even then they get lost."
And so I think that I'll ask
a related question to this.
We've talked a lot about kind of myths,
the things we haven't found,
what does work for
learning, and particularly,
maybe problem solving to
get at Mal's question.
- Well, a lot of stuff works
in education, actually,
not everything works and
nothing works all of the time,
but there is a lot of things
we know that can do the job.
And we know that basic knowledge
and arithmetics and reading comprehension
can help you a long way.
But then there's also the
part of problem solving.
We've seen for instance, from research,
like project follow through,
but also from research by the OCD,
with the PISA results
and things like that,
that base, a good solid basic knowledge
can help you and also can
help you to solve problems.
But then you get,
you need the opportunity
to get in touch with this
kind of problems and get the hang of it.
So if you in education,
if you have a good basic knowledge,
if you have a lot background
knowledge, can help you too.
But also you, if you
see a lot of examples,
good examples of how problems are solved.
If you get this,
not only in one topic,
but in several topics.
Maybe in integrated topics,
but then also give you
the opportunity to try
and fail,
but learn from the failures,
then you'll get a long way,
just like you have to
learn how to read a book,
how to write a sentence.
It's also important to learn
how to solve a problem.
- Yeah., so background knowledge,
practice with feedback and whether
- it's right or not.
- With feedback.
- Yes.
(Kristen laughs)
- And, and, and, you know,
there's something that I want to add
because when people are thinking that,
when people know we are
writing about urban myths,
they often think it's black or white,
but we use three categories in our books.
The first category is total nonsense.
First, for instance, learning styles,
those are now total nonsense.
If you're discussing some
other topics like multiple
intelligences, then we say it's nuanced.
And for some topics we
have to say, we don't know,
because even in science, there
are a lot of discussions.
Let's take the 21st century skills,
it's a topic that's also very popular
and closely related to problem solving.
Now,
there are two discussions
in the scientific world
that we don't have a solution yet,
but that are really relevant
for this kind of discussions in education.
The first element we
are not sure about is,
is it actually a skill
or is it rather a personality trait?
For instance creativity,
is something that you can learn
or is it something you need to develop?
That's the first point of discussion.
The second point of
discussion is how generic
are those skills?
Because for instance,
I can be very creative
in playing the guitar,
but it doesn't mean then I'm
very creative as for instance,
a plumber, trust me, I'm not.
So how generic are those skills.
And we don't have the answer
on these questions yet,
but I do think they are very important
to help us further in education.
- Yeah, so this idea that
research is evolving,
I think, is an important one
and that we don't always
have all the answers,
but psychology itself recently
has been through quite a reckoning on
some things that we thought
were true after trying to
replicate those findings,
we're seeing aren't replicating so well.
So do you see some, some
of that pattern too?
- Yeah.
Thank you for bringing this up, actually.
Erik Erickson once described
that crisis means growth.
Well, if that's the case,
psychology has been through
a major period of growth,
the biggest period of
growth in the history,
because it's true.
A lot of classic studies have
been replicated for the past
10, 11 years and failed.
And there was new new book
coming up next year, next summer,
THe Psychology of Great Teaching
and together with Casper and Liese,
what we have tried to do
is trying to figure out
what is still standing
and what should be left, left behind.
And some of the big
theories, for instance,
very popular in teacher training, Piaget,
is one of the victims.
But on the other side,
there's also great news because yes,
there's a lot of stuff that
wasn't able to being replicated,
but there are also a lot of
things that are now standing
stronger than ever.
For instance, if we look at dual coding,
a lot of cognitive science
that has been used in education
for the past 10, 15 years,
we have now a bigger knowledge confirming,
scientific knowledge
confirming those insights,
- But,
- [Kristen] Great.
- It has been, it has been
a very strange period.
- It has, it has.
So you're just kind of
dropped dual coding.
Can you tell, talk to
folks about dual coding
if they're not familiar with that?
- Oh, sorry for that.
Dual coding is the idea that
if you combine images and words,
we have two channels
in our working memory,
a channel of for words,
a channel for images.
If you use them both,
there is a bigger chance
that will be learned.
Okay, but wait,
if you put too much pressure
on one of both channels,
then you are getting less learning.
For instance, if there
are too much images,
if the images don't relate
to what is being taught,
people will learn less.
But also if you have words on the screen
that are exactly the same
of what is being said,
then the word channel gets overloaded.
And again, students will learn less.
- That, that makes
sense that it's not just
put all the information you
can through both channels,
there's nuance to it
and how to do it well.
And what that looks like.
- Yeah.
I think that's the biggest
task we have as scientists.
Not telling people "Do this
and miracles will happen."
No, "Do this and maybe
this will have an effect.
And if it doesn't work, please try this."
because it's easy for gurus to say,
"do this and everything will better
and you will even smell better."
But,
(both laughing)
in real life,
it's much more complicated than that.
Can I give you an example?
- Yes, please.
And it's,
it's connecting several dots
because we received a lot of
questions about growth mindset.
And it's a topic in our second myth book,
but also a topic in the psychology book.
And Carol Dweck is not the guru.
And I can prove you, she's not a guru.
She's a real scientist
because a lot of the
studies that were performed
on a group mindset,
had a very small group of
students being involved
in the study.
And for the past couple of years,
there has been real that replication
and credit to Carol Dweck,
she also participated in research
on replicating her original studies.
And we found out that the
effect of growth mindset on
average is not that enormous.
Well, it's really small.
But the main words in my
previous sentence was on average
because we see that for some
children, for some students,
it can even have a negative effect
to stimulate a growth mindset.
But if the average is small
or nothing, close to nothing,
and some pupils have a negative effect,
then it's not hard to
imagine that other students,
other pupils can have a positive effect.
And we see that for instance,
children from,
younger children from
more poor backgrounds,
they can benefit from a
growth mindset approach.
So for us,
it's very important not to
say throw growth mindset,
throw growth mindset away,
but when will we use it,
for who will we use it,
but also keep an eye on the effects
because maybe in your case,
it's gonna have a
perfect, splendid effect,
but maybe it's the opposite.
And then it's you as a teacher or educator
or as a team to say,
let's do something else.
- Yes, so Sarah,
Sarah Hem from YouTube, you asks if,
if Pedro could say something
about motivation myths.
So there's a piece about a mindset,
a mindset,
and how think about motivation
from growth mindset.
That's I think important.
Anything else on motivation?
- Oh,
I can tell a lot of them about motivation
because there's a lot
about it in the new book,
but I give you two very
interesting insights.
The first thing we often
think about you have,
or intrinsic motivation
or extrinsic motivation
and intrinsic is good
and extrinsic is bad,
but it's much, much more complicated.
For instance,
there are a couple of versions
of extrinsic motivation,
and I can give you again,
a very simple example.
You have a student who
wants to become a doctor.
He or she is really
motivated to become a doctor,
but he or she is not
really into mathematics,
but they noticed that student knows that
if I want to become a doctor,
I really need this kind of mathematics.
Then that student,
isn't motivated intrinsically
for mathematics,
but has a good, positive
extrinsic motivation.
Please keep that kind of motivation.
But also,
and this will surprise a lot of you.
We know that a lot of people
think the more passionate you
are about the subject, the better,
but there is an issue with that
because we know
that if you're really, really
passionate about something,
but you don't have
anything else in your life,
then there is this bigger
chance that when you have,
whenever you get too
into a problem or hurdle
that you will give up.
if you have a passion,
but you also have something
on the side, something else,
another hobby,
then you are more resilient
for any kind of setbacks
you can encounter trying
to achieve your passion.
So the idea of being more
motivated or more passionate
is better.
It's again, much more
complicated than that.
- Yes.
Okay, So this relates to a
question from Alex Marelli,
from YouTube, who says,
"You mentioned your son
not liking to memorize his
multiplication tables.
How important is student
drive in learning?"
And I think there's a followup question of
if a student's not
motivated to do something,
how do you try to get them to
be motivated to do something?
- Yeah, yeah.
That's the $1 million question
because we all, first of all,
I think we have to accept
even us as a teacher.
We're not always that
motivated for every single part
of the things we are doing.
So that's.
- Sometimes I treat myself with chocolate
to get through a task
that I have to do, I know.
- You should come to Belgium,
the best chocolates in the world.
I wasn't paid for that, okay.
(both laughing)
But going back to the question,
one of the things is we to find
that they experience kind of success.
So if it's too difficult or too easy,
I think a first step is
make sure that everything is
a possible challenge.
It's a challenge,
but a challenge that they can achieve,
you know, the, the classic
concept of scaffolding,
good teaching is building scaffolds to,
for every child to learn.
Sometimes you will need a kind of rewards
to get things started,
but there another element
and that's often overlooked.
We've all had teachers,
that teaches on subjects that
we weren't interested in.
But surprisingly we were
by the end of the class
because the teacher,
he or himself was so passionate about
and passion can be very contagious.
So,
try to be motivated yourself, showed us,
try to explain why you're motivated,
but also try to explain
why the child needs this.
Because I have to admit,
discussing my son again,
as an example, I don't like anecdotes,
but I want to use this
to explain something,
is that well, I didn't convince him,
but he did it because he thought,
"Well, if my dad thinks it's important,
it will probably be important."
But later on,
he came to me and said, "You were right.
I need this."
And sometimes you have to
ask a kind of leap of faith
from your student or children.
We know you, I know it's hard now,
but you'll get by.
And then you'll figure
out why you need this.
But one last remark on this.
If you don't know why do you need this,
why your students need this,
and the only answer is it's
because it's in the textbook
or in the curriculum, then
you're in deep trouble.
Because if you can't answer that question,
how can you motivate your children?
- That, that totally makes sense.
It sounds like a good
place to leave us on.
I could have talked to
you for much longer,
but we are already at the
end of our time today.
Thank you so much for joining us.
- Oh, it was great fun, thank you.
- Excellent.
And I want to, again,
recommend to everyone,
both the existing books on
urban myths in learning and
education.
And we look forward to your
forthcoming book as well.
Thank you and everyone have a great day.